bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur
arte france
est-ce que la situation dont la prison
de fleury mérogis est sous contrôle
est-ce que les seconds rôles je pense
que c'était plus l'administration
pénitentiaire qui serait aujourd'hui en
mesure de vous répondre en tout cas ce
qu'on peut en dire c'est que aujourd'hui
on est à 22 cas positifs sur la prison
de fleury mérogis là un bâtiment complet
a été mis sous cloche pour pouvoir
effectivement endiguer l'éventuelle
propagation du coronavirus donc le le
bâtiment les activités sont aujourd'hui
très très très limité les parloirs
en tout cas les détenus qui sont
confinés se retrouve en fait sans
parloir donc pour l'instant où
l'administration ni des mesures
supplémentaires pour effectivement
permettre de contenir cette éventuelle
contamination et de retrouver une
situation normale le plus rapidement
possible
certains détenus auraient refusé le
dépistage est ce que celle là est ce que
cela fausse le protocole sanitaire qui a
été mise en place
alors on a eu effectivement un refus
concernant 200 personnes détenues qui
ont refusé le test
derrière il ya eu une réaction
automatique de
l'administration puisque ces 200
individus ont été placés en confinement
pour une durée de sept jours avec une
interdiction complète d'activités et
aussi de visites
donc ensuite effectivement la grosse
difficulté par rapport à ça c'est non
pas les gens qui éventuellement vont
développer des symptômes du colisée où
là il y aura plus de doutes et par
contre ce sera plus pour les personnes
qui aident effectivement sous dit
asymptomatique et où là ma foi ça va
être très compliqué à pouvoir à pouvoir
détecter
alors ça fait des trous dans la raquette
ça c'est une certitude
derrière il y as forcément de toute
façon des mesures qui se met en place au
fur et à mesure et où la situation en
tout cas il est l'administration essaye
de la contrôler et de la meilleure façon
qui soit et ces mesures sanitaires à ce
qu'elle vous semble suffisante pour
protéger à la fois les détenus mais
aussi et les surveillants dans les
prisons aujourd'hui quand on regarde un
peu les chiffres concernant notamment
les personnels on se rend compte que
selon les dernières communications de
l'administration qui datent de la
semaine dernière on était à 189
personnel pénitentiaire positif sur
l'ensemble du ministère ça représente à
peu près 50% des personnels du ministère
de la justice
derrière il ya effectivement toutes ces
mesures sanitaires la distanciation le
port du masque etc etc qui sont mises en
place
alors on peut aujourd'hui s'interroger
sur notamment sur les masques est ce
qu'il n'y ait pas temps aujourd'hui
commandé des masques de type ffp2 et en
doter les personnels puisque on sait
qu'il ya aujourd'hui des variants que la
tension est beaucoup plus importante
qu'il ya ça qui un jour ou trois
semaines donc il ya sûrement un problème
aussi au niveau des ministres à sion
pénitentiaire en termes d'anticipation
et on en a un autre exemple qui n'est
pas typique de de cléry mérogis mais qui
est par exemple à la maison d'arrêt de
nice où au final on a attendu qu'il soit
trop tard pour prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent et est confiné et mettre en
place des campagnes de dépistage
tout dépend aussi effectivement de la
manière dont les choses sont gérées
localement parce qu'on n'a pas une
gestion qui est hétérogène sur
l'ensemble du territoire
papa qui n'est pas homogène pardon c'est
en fonction
des directeurs en fonction des chefs de
services en fonction de la manière dont
ils vont appréhender le phénomène et les
réactions qui vont avoir pour anticiper
les éventuels problèmes
vous avez des endroits où ça se passe
très bien et puis d'autres endroits où
malheureusement on a affaire à des gens
qui sont dépassés par les événements et
où derrière ça engendre des conséquences
et en matière de gestion de population
pénale et en même temps de gestion de
risque sanitaire pour les personnels
parce qu'il faut garder à l'esprit que
ces personnels vous rentrer chez eux
une fois le service terminé et donc un
risque aussi de contamination pour leurs
proches et leurs familles et ça là
dessus pour nous c'est quelque chose qui
est totalement inacceptable
on a une obligation l'administration a
une obligation de protéger ses
personnels est de protéger aussi des
proches de ces de ses personnels en
imaginez vous l'évoquez à l'instinct on
imagine que ces mesures sanitaires ont
aussi des répercussions dans les
présents sur le comportement des détenus
quelle est la situation
dans les prisons parmi les détenus si on
fait un comparatif par rapport à ce qui
a pu se passer lors du tout premier
confinement il ya environ un an
quand on fait un comparatif aussi avec
ce qui s'était passé notamment dans les
prisons italiennes où vous savez était
quelque part de grosses émeutes en
france on a eu quand même un peu de
chance on a peut-être une bonne étoile
et août les choses se déroulent à peu
près calmement on n'a pas une
augmentation finalement des violences
quelles qu'elles soient qu'elle soit
physique ou verbale on n'a pas une
augmentation liée finalement aux mesures
sanitaires
on en reste aux violences habituelles
alors avec 2,6 de la dea des points un
peu plus chaud parce que quand un
personnel doit malheureusement mettre un
terme à un parloir parce que les gestes
barrière ne sont pas respectées
fatalement l'art sacré de la tension
mais d'un point de vue global on ne peut
pas dire que ces mesures sanitaires
aujourd'hui ont des répercussions en
termes de tension entre les personnels
et la population pénale
heureusement d'ailleurs pour autant
aujourd'hui on peut s'interroger
finalement sur la pertinence de
certaines d'entre elles je vous parlais
de notamment des parloirs
aujourd'hui on a des dispositifs de
séparation en plexiglas qui sont bas
fois un peu fait petit bricolage vous
prenez de la même chose dans les prisons
espagnoles ce sont de véritables boxe
avec des vrais vitre de séparation et un
système d'interphonie pour pouvoir
communiquer avec la famille et où là les
personnels ne sont pas mis à
contribution pour vérifier que les
gestes barrières sont effectivement
respectées donc là la tension le baisse
d'un cran ce pas tellement parce qu'on
sait que le parloir c'est le moment le
plus difficile à gérer dans la mesure où
naturellement les personnes quand elles
se voient elles sont amenées à avoir
envie de se toucher ça peut se
comprendre c'est humain mais derrière on
sait les répercussions que ça va avoir
donc balles a ajouté ce type de mission
personnels pénitentiaires en supplément
de tout ce qui a à gérer par rapport à
cette situation sanitaire
ce n'est peut-être pas finalement la
meilleure des choses merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions sur rt france où il ferait de
fond que je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire national du fap unsa justice